ludovic de foucauld bonjour à vous
ludovic vous êtes à antalya pour nous je
le disais donc pas d'avancée pas de
cessez-le-feu c'est ce qu'a regretté
d'ailleurs le chef de la diplomatie
ukrainienne ce qu'il faut comprendre
ludovic c'est finalement tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment dépasse le l'envoyé
spécial le chef de la diplomatie russe
et et que ça se joue plutôt du côté du
kremlin
bonjour à bien oui effectivement ça se
joue au niveau de l'échelon supérieur au
niveau présidentiel
nous ne nous attendions pas un miracle a
dit le ministre turc des affaires
étrangères mais vous le chevauchement
qui a pris la parole en dernier ne vont
pas nous n'avions pas de grandes
espérances mais nous savons que c'est
une première prise de contact d'une
première étape dans un processus qui
aboutirait c'est l'espoir de la
diplomatie turque à une rencontre
directe entre les présidents zelensky et
poutine est d'ailleurs chao chelou a
expliqué que lavrov lui a dit que le
président russe n'était pas défavorable
à l'idée de rencontrer son homologue
ukrainien et zelensky de son côté
s'était déjà dit disposé à faire de même
mais on comprend bien qu'il est
impossible de parvenir aujourd'hui à des
décisions et des mesures concrètes si on
n'est pas à l'échelon présidentielle et
vous l'avez dit c'est ce qu'a regretté
le ministre ukrainien des affaires
étrangères qui est dit en substance moi
je suis venu de bonne foi prêt à engager
la responsabilité de mon pays pour
notamment améliorer la situation
humanitaire catastrophique
particulièrement à marioupol mais
j'avais en face de moi je cite toujours
évidemment le ministre ukrainien j'avais
en face de moi quelqu'un qui écoutait
mais qui ne disait rien qui prendra
peut-être en compte les demandes ou pas
et qui les portera peut-être à
moscou mais il n'y a pas de possibilité
de mesures tant qu'on va pas l'échelon
supérieur on avait quand même et une
drôle de temps adam d'impression d'un
côté on a dans la salle de presse
du ministre ukrainien un homme qui
explique que marioupol et sous les
bombes russe et qu'il faut absolument
venir en aide à ces à ces civils et à
quelques dizaines de mètres de là au
même moment dans une conférence de
presse simultané le ministre lavrov qui
expliquait que non son pays n'avait pas
envahi l'ukraine
et quel intérêt ludovic pour la turquie
de s'immiscer de tenter de jouer un rôle
dans ce conflit qui se posait en faiseur
de paix pourrir douanes
la turquie est très bien placé pour
jouer ce rôle de neutralité active c'est
comme ça que la diplomatie turque
l'appel parce que elle s'entend bien
avec les deux parties elle est alliée de
fait avec l'ukraine mais elle entretient
aussi une relation très intéressante
avec la russie et redonne et et poutine
s'entendent bien même si leur pays
parfois défendre des positions rival sur
de nombreux théâtres dans le monde ils
parviennent toujours au moins à en
discuter et la turquie aujourd'hui on le
voit sort de son isolement diplomatique
dans lequel elle était un petit peu
coincé un ces derniers mois surtout
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de joe biden
turquie avait parié sur une réélection
de donald trump meyer de haan et donald
trump s'entendaient très bien joe biden
n'a pas fait mystère de ce qu'il pensait
de son homologue turc il avait quand
même dire publiquement je vous le
rappelle qu'il aurait aimé voir
l'opposition gagné les gouvernés en
turquie mais aujourd'hui la turquie
déploie une offensive diplomatique tous
azimuts qui va au delà de la médiation
dans le conflit russo ukrainien en se
réconciliant par exemple avec tous ses
voisins dans la région le président
israélien était à ankara hier quand même
et donc la turquie voilà retrouve la
voix qui était la sienne dans le concert
des nations et fait plus que jamais
partie de la conversation est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui à 18h30 heure locale
c'est-à-dire 16h30 heure de paris le
président werden sont s'entretiendra
avec son homologue américain joe biden
par téléphone merci beaucoup